hello and welcome to this video as River
Boca again I'm not sure I have a plane I
always gotta find ya always got white
what's the first black game
yeah in new zone with g3 it's an
interesting variation in general I mean
it's also interesting way of playing for
white let's see how we handle this queen
d3 is not the most challenging move
hmm
what is it what does it display to two
against two lifetimes corn hmm but this
looks like three I don't quite get this
yeah it's not so important but why why
does it display two against two
it's odd
yeah I think you're just Castle here me
I remember this correctly it's been a
while since I checked those things
these six I'm wondering about c5 after
the six whom
I wonder about Queen c7 if I can do that
there there is sometimes you can
sometimes do this and just go to b8
after 95
played that quite quickly I mean this is
actually if you don't get any immediate
benefit from this move that does this
doesn't help at all because like d6
sorry eight-six is something that I
would have played anyhow so these six
now let's start with that
but I don't know if a six is really
helping me but yeah I probably have to
do it I mean if like if he goes back
Queen to c7 we get to the point where c4
is just hanging
in just 19 see for what why cannot allow
him yeah that's you know that's may be
necessary if it is some things are fine
for me okay now what now would be eight
you would really like to move the bishop
someday
okay yeah there are some impossible
setups here then I'm not sure about
running do I want to play b6 in such a
situation or stuff to say this was the
other thing that I was not sure about I
that Bishop is just on f2 he is doing
threatening night a six yeah
[Music]
and 93
okay I should have played at five
especially 93 is an absolute pain okay
this covers be age I have five was for
some bad decision I shouldn't have done
that
in particular considering that I was
probably very okay with normal moves at
same
what do what is he doing here I really
don't get it okay
Bishop Jake's or queen chains
no time went want is on c6 anyway I can
take and take B aids I'm such a [ __ ] ah
no no no no
that's such a section should not be
there that was a totally winning
position and now no idea what's going on
maybe it's so ok but the two rooks are
always difficult to play against I just
threatened one chick I don't know
and I know what looks like made but I
have two chicks him
double-checking rook and pawn on g3 whoa
whoo that was tough it was tough and a
bit unnecessary okay so like here this
is a theoretical position already still
I mean any good one because white has
played 23 which is really somewhat
dubious move it is some better to play
Bishop d2 after which I think black is
okay as I analyzed in my in my book but
it's not nothing nothing special of
course I got the numbering wrong let me
it's a bit late if it's just before make
it worse the next video that is four
five five eight actually okay so Queen
d3 and the reason why this is imprecise
is exactly this move over here or the
sequence here you get this double pawns
to play against white of course has
files and the great diagonal on G to it
I think everything considered black is
fine
Knight b5 going back how Queen c5 is
also an idea
okay well cream ba this is a normal move
castles d6 I think I'm just doing quite
normal things here this is actually not
liked a lot by the engine which wants to
play Bishop c5 which is yeah looks looks
fine then a six and d6 yeah why not
okay Queen to b4 that that's the kind of
move you can easily miss
Marco billion trying to take him and
these six hangs of course yeah I was a
bit a lot better I was a lot better for
him yeah I'm very okay right yeah yeah
it's difficult to not take only five at
some stage if you did so immediately
yeah the engine wants to play f5
immediately here a fiber form okay it's
not a bad move a for Bishop c5 fields
also quite logical to me and she doesn't
like it
91 93 okay okay would be one f5 it took
me ages to see Bishop a set from them
not really a long time and now I'm I
mean in great shape and this I didn't
get it almost like putting the knight on
to completely into the wilderness here
yeah take take and and this should not
have any further excitement but it did
okay this this wasn't the best I was
just doing it for simplicity's sake and
Bishop c6 and actually likes
now maybe I'm right they played
something's German I was really not
liking this but it seems some season it
seems I'm winning
a stupider king/queen everyone of course
yeah just just wins everything but I was
somehow panicky in this situation
you know he didn't make the draw yeah I
know
I was again I was a bit in panic yeah
age six is a draw
probably let lose us though yeah moving
in too much stuff look II 7s the only
way to draw that's not very intuitive
wins the house now yeah yeah it could
have been a draw if you repeat it but
all in all I should not told the
undeserved that I wonders it was winning
most of the time yeah but but still very
tricky to play yeah thanks a lot for
watching